hello folks welcome to rational science
I hope you can all hear me fine
uh you can see me find uh I'm on the
road
and first of all happy Halloween we're
gonna be doing a little bit of spirits
and ghosts here as well today we're
going to be talking about quasis crazies
the crazy crazies
um and like I said I'm on the road
and because of that
um you know as a result of that I got to
see uh something I can't see in Germany
I had to get out of Germany to see it
and that's uh RT the Russian news
network uh be able to read uh news from
the other side of the uh wall
and so um the the issue is that you know
in Germany uh they're censored
and outside uh Germany they're not and
so I was able to see some of the
headlines these are some of the
headlines that had appeared today in RT
you know and you can see
um that a lot of it is propaganda right
uh for their side of the world but what
caught my attention was the headline
there Germany's inflation worse than
expected so you can see that some of the
news that RT is uh you know spreading
around uh has to be is designed to uh
you know to lessen the impact on uh on
their war effort
that the you know that the West is
uh bring you up against them anyways uh
here's another bit of news from from one
of the Articles you can see why maybe
the Germans
are uh censoring it uh RT you know here
you can see it Washington's seeking to
weaken EU
and you know there I I just underlined a
couple of lines of making crazy money
the Americans are making crazy money by
selling gas to European States at
exorbitant prices
and at
um it's going to lead to the the
industrialization of the EU that's what
the Russians say that this war is about
okay
and uh yeah maybe some of that is true
the questions whether I need uh Uncle
Otto Kraut to censor the news for me you
know I think I can uh reach my own
decisions I don't need uh the government
to tell me what to hear and not to hear
okay that's the way I look at it but and
I think they they do themselves a
disfavor
uh primarily because they uh boast that
they have freedom of the press freedom
of speech
and here they censor you know the
Russian Network
and people might say well the Russians
are censoring the West as well
yeah but see there's a difference in the
difference is that the East never
claimed that they had freedom of speech
or freedom of the press the West does it
boasts about it and in fact there was a
uh I recall there was uh I think it was
a 1980s uh when the Soviet Union was
still around and they interviewed a
Russian uh some kind of uh politician or
whoever
and from the United States and he said
the following he says the Americans
think they are free we know we are not
and that more or less uh puts it in the
right perspective you know
um the question is which is more
dangerous you know when you know that
you're being censored uh or when you
don't know that you're being censored
and yeah I don't think it uh it's good
for the West the other thing is that you
know I'm not sure that this changes
anything the fact that they censor news
from the East because uh again a lot of
people already have made up their minds
uh which side they're on you know so to
speak and uh and I don't think the news
is going to change much of that
anyways here we have another bit of news
related to that and came out a
a few months ago about a month ago a
little over a month ago and that's about
that North stream pipeline you know
number two and it was blown up in that
North stream pipeline was supposed to
bring some oil and gas uh to the West
some energy you know to the to the West
especially to Germany and
um you know because of the war in
Ukraine that never happened now they
blew it up blew it up about a month ago
here it is westbound Nordstrom too cause
it caused gas pipeline leaks that's
according to Putin he says that the West
did it okay and the West pointed fingers
back at Putin you know and says no that
he did it uh so who did it well we don't
know turns out that someone sent me a
link and I thought I'd share it with you
and it's got to do with uh Joe Biden
he's tying the world
who did it and here he goes listen
carefully
if Russia invades that means tanks or
troops crossing the uh the border of
Ukraine again then uh there will be uh
we there will be no longer on North
stream too we we will bring it into it
how would you how will you do that
exactly since the project and control of
the project is within Germany's control
we will I promise you we'll be able to
do it
okay so um
you know you can say well the Russians
did it anyways could be you know I mean
these things do happen
but see now the uh ball is in uh the uh
in Biden's court because he's got a
justify that he did not do it how's he
going to prove it
so right now the way things stand
because of what he said you know it is
the United States who did it it can't
get away from that and uh you know my my
feeling on all this is that really I
don't care one bit about the war in
Ukraine I don't think that's that's not
where my focus is my focus is on the U.S
economy if you which is related to the
extinction Theory if the U.S economy
falls apart it's the end of the world
okay that's that's what I'm going to
propose to anyone who will listen we
cannot let the United States while it's
too big to fail the Empire's too big at
this point and uh the way I see it you
know they had to expand into Europe
without firing a shot letting the
Russians do all the work over there and
all they had to do was enter Europe and
Conquer Europe so I think uh yeah there
is uh right now A takeover of Europe and
maybe there is going to be a deep
industrialization of Europe
uh I think the United States will have
more influence already has but we'll
have even more influence as time goes by
both militarily and economically so
we'll see what happens uh right now I
don't care as long as the United States
uh Empire doesn't fall apart
I think that's what we have to preserve
okay talking about extension the
possibility of Extinction one file says
it says you aren't making any
predictions about when exactly extension
will take place so nothing that is
currently going on is necessarily an
indicator of collapse
uh well uh what's going on is the
conquest of Europe that's what's going
on as far as I'm concerned that's the
important thing that's going on right
now and
um we'll see where that leads if the
American economy Can Survive by taking
over Europe
let's do it I don't I don't care you
know uh countries and empires have
changed throughout history so that's not
gonna blow me away at least I think this
examination makes sense from a point of
view about case study seeing things
happening in the media and speculating
how this fits in with a potential or
even hypothetical overall collapse
scenario as outlined in your theory
personally I am optimistic about our
chances so for me it is like a thought
experiment
well I can tell you is that from my
point of view I don't uh first of all I
want to say that I'm not pessimistic or
optimistic or anything like that I call
it realistic okay it's a theory I'm
saying uh we're gonna apply the theory
of Extinction the mass extinction that
occurred to animals in the past and I am
applying that theory to us to us humans
I'm saying we cannot avoid the same
mechanism and so this is a question of
an objective issue it's not a question
of whether I'm optimistic or pessimistic
it's just realistic and the way I see it
you know right now the the big problem
is that the global economy is in big
problems it's in big problems because
it's not expanding as well as it should
we had the covid now we have this war
and other Wars is going around uh the
planet and the problem right now is that
I don't think uh we have too much more
to go as far as growth on planet Earth
economic growth and if there is no
economic growth if growth economic
growth comes to a standstill like
definitely like permanently we're all in
trouble okay all the economies need to
expand uh the human economy is an
inverted pyramid scheme we have to have
more sales more growth year after year
after year after year at least long term
if we reach a plateau and we have no uh
perspectives no projections further up
ahead going you know expanding if the
projections are also that we're coming
down
uh it's the end of man okay the global
economy cannot go down it has to
continue growing and growing growing and
it cannot grow forever
so uh yeah it's not a question of being
pessimistic or optimistic it's a
question of being realistic and just
smiling the theory to the letter uh to
the letter you know to every word that's
in there okay another fella he makes a
comment on the extinction he says did
you identify the mechanism for extension
of plants as old age
what is old about a baby dinosaur
well this poor follow I mean Jesus and
uh he said the jeans are the genes the
mechanism for extinction the older
species the more susceptible to disease
predation or what how did I miss your
physical mechanism in nature that
explains the Cretaceous tertiary
extinctions I am as ignorant at the end
of your videos when your video started
well I'm really sorry that the spot
didn't have the um
uh intelligence to understand the theory
of Extinction maybe he didn't listen to
uh the theories maybe he uh maybe I
don't know if I explained it in any
detail last time so maybe that's what he
was waiting for the issue is that yeah
baby dinosaurs have nothing to do with
the age of a species but I guess that
went from one ear through the other with
nothing to stop it in between just space
time
uh so here let me just point these
things out see if we can zero in on what
the mechanism is first I start by saying
that we should study uh Extinction 101
before we do Extinction 102 101 is the
animals in the past 102 is human
extinction okay so I like to make a
separation between those two we must
first learn the mechanism of extension
before we apply it to man okay and
um so uh the first thing we have to note
is that Extinction 102 you know the
extinction of man is not a prediction
and a lot of people have trouble with
that understanding that no it's an
explanation what we're explaining is a
mechanism okay and
um no mechanism is economics and all
animals had and have economics they
manage food management of resources is
economic and every animal including us
we all manage food okay we're saying
that the mass extinction of the
disappearing disappearance of a food
chain therefore it's related to food and
um the extinction 101 explains the mass
extinction okay so uh uh you have to
take extension 101 first before we can
get to something else now this fell did
uh question Extinction 101 but the
problem is he knows very little if he's
gonna say that a tiny dinosaur a baby
dinosaur is not an old species okay so I
guess his logic fails right there okay
but here it is uh let's uh go in Little
Steps little baby steps for people who
are hard of understanding okay we're not
trying to convince people we're trying
to make people understand what the
theory is okay so stay tuned to the uh
or tune in to the uh Theory not not to
not to believe or prove or anything like
that okay so here it goes uh there were
different ages okay throughout the
history of life on Earth and here you
have the gymnosperms they were the Flora
the primary Flora of the age of the
dinosaurs and the dinosaurs preceded the
mammals that's why the dinosaurs were an
older species than the mammals just like
the synapses were an older species than
the dinosaurs and the amphibians were an
older uh generic species right family or
whatever then the synapses okay and for
each age you had a different type of
food different type of vegetation
so um what happens when the vegetation
goes away which as you can see it did
okay well you would think that when some
of that vegetation goes away the one
that they the animals got used to after
millions of years you know when it goes
away the animals also go away and that's
essentially the the overall Theory okay
when the plants die the and the
herbivores die and the uh predators that
preyed upon them die as well that's
essentially the theory the big picture
okay
so uh there's a lot of details that
people want to know and yeah
we can't get to all the details here but
I just want people to understand the big
picture big picture is
plants and animals go together certain
animals uh are born and grow and radiate
with a certain type of plants millions
of years later many dynasties of plants
and animals later at some point the type
of plant disappears gradually disappears
is taken over by another plant which the
animals
ruling dynasties do not eat can't eat
okay
mammals we we don't eat ferns mammals we
do not eat conifers gymnosperms okay we
eat angiosperms okay so if tomorrow the
ferns and all the conifers on planet
Earth die
we won't miss a thing they're just there
for beauty okay if you cover the
landscape that's it we have primarily
angiosperms on planet Earth I think 90
of the Flora is angiosperms are
angiosperms okay
um
so what happened how did the dinosaurs
die well they ate conifers they ate uh
cycads uh cicadioids and uh
ginkgo's you know uh so so they had all
these plants and probably uh you know
some a lot of uh taller
um
conifers and this was the vegetation
that they grew up with if you look at
their expansion the expansion of
dinosaurs it was with conifers the ferns
were dying
and so were the mammal-like reptiles and
uh afterwards the archosaurus and what
grew after that
was irradiated were the conifers
together with the dinosaurs and guess
what happened millions of years later
several or thousands of dynasties later
well when their Plant World was dying
conifers were dying the angiosperms were
taking over the land muscling them aside
okay kind of uh they were muscleing them
aside because the conifers had already
completed their cycle of life
uh they develop as much as they could
not only did their Gene genetic
diversity disappear but they were
archaic plants compared to the vibrant
new angiosperms that were spreading
everywhere so a lot of the uh uh forests
and jungles of uh conifers
were being replaced by the angiosperms
not because really the edge of sperms
weren't really muscling them aside even
though that's a term that I use what was
happening in the conifers were not
reproducing and spreading as they were
when they radiated millions of years
earlier and so the dinosaurs they were
caught in these what I call shrinking
Islands
shrinking forests and shrinking jungles
and they were caught with less and less
food at the time that they were really
expanding in numbers because they had
beaten or gotten used to many of the
diseases after millions of years as well
you know they were more or less
sedentary Animals by then I'm saying
that what happens is
atomos migrate and at some point you
know they they reach a certain location
and they become more sedentary the more
sedentary the more they get used to
diseases that used to kill their
ancestors and at some point you know
they live longer they have longer lives
they can expand in numbers
but the jungles are shrinking under
their feet okay so that's in general the
process
okay and here you see evidence for those
who look for evidence there was a
four-year study known as the Cretaceous
terrestrial Revolution okay this is
related to the dinosaurs specifically
okay and here it is you can see what
happened throughout the Cretaceous well
the angiosperms were expanding not only
a number of species but they were also
expanding in volume on Earth the cycads
the ferns the you know in general all
the conifers and ferns they were dying
in other words they were going away okay
and it was the ancest burns that were
taking over the land and so who do you
think eats angiosperms what was the
mammals so the mammals radiated the
little tiny mammals that were at the
feet of the dinosaurs were radiating
with the angiosperms that were covering
the land and meanwhile the big guys the
ruling dynasties they were dying because
uh they were old as well as species so
were the plants that they ate and it all
came to a head over there uh about 65
million years ago so this is also uh I
think
reinforces the theory okay what we find
in the record okay and uh so it's very
important to see this okay when animals
were born and we're in different types
of animals were born why were the
dinosaurs and older species than the uh
mammals well they were older because
they started a lot uh earlier than us
they started with when the conifers
radiated there were no angiosperms on
planet Earth at the time so uh mammals
could not have developed because mammals
developed with the angiosperms okay and
here you see the map you can see that
the dinosaurs preceded the mammals that
start over there at uh purgatorius and
even a little earlier there but they
started around the end of the Triassic
beginning of the Jurassic that's when
mammals began okay that's when they
developed that's that's the far as far
bag as is we can trace them on the other
hand you can see what happened with the
Dinosaurs they preceded us and they
were the ones who radiated with economy
economy okay so uh in general that's the
theory the theory is that plants
disappeared the animals that forged a
long-term relationship with them
disappear with them and that's what's
going to happen to us our plant life is
going to disappear because we produce it
no money
no food that's how simple it is
okay let's move on to the crazies The
Crazies okay crazy quas eyes
what is a quasi what is a quasi quasi
you can say it either way uh here you
have a picture if you look it up you'll
see stuff like this out there okay
and you say what am I staring at what is
it rather I mean they're pretty pictures
you know uh but what are we staring at
and here's another uh picture of the
same thing okay
okay so these are what people uh usually
illustrate for quasies quasis okay
okay so what are we staring at what are
these things
they don't look like uh things because
they look like things in motion they
were all uh moving pictures not
snapshots okay
and so it seems like it's got something
to do with behavior
when you look at the queer quasi or
quasi okay that's what you find okay you
find that uh it means just the word
quasi right as if okay or uh manner of
acting like it relates to behavior in
fact uh uh one came above Quasimodo okay
uh from The Hunchback of Notre Dame
um
uh he got that name because he was
delivered at the doorsteps of the church
there
um on Quasimodo Sunday uh which are the
first few words of one of the uh
things that they read in the Catholic
Church okay Quasimodo Kennedy infantes
okay so um what does it mean it means
how something behaves it really quasi or
quasi or quasi refers to behavior it
does not refer to a thing a standalone
static thing so we're going to be
talking about behaviors keep this in
mind uh word Behavior how something
behaves okay and so here you have it
um on the other side give me a second
here
here we have uh
a definition of quasi-particle Quasi
particle and Collective excitations are
closely related what emergent phenomena
emergent phenomena what do you mean uh I
thought uh they're talking about
particle and it's an emergent phenomena
doesn't sound like a thing in here uh we
look up emergent phenomena to find out
what that is here's our emergent
properties when uh simple entities
interact to produce more complex ones
and emergent Behavior or emergent
property can appear when a number of
simple entities operate in an
environment forming more complex
behaviors as a collective
occurs when an entity is observed to
have properties its parts do not have on
their own properties or behaviors that
emerge only when Parts interact in a
wider hole
okay so uh we're talking about again
behavior and emergent meaning you know
that uh out of a group some Behavior
uh emerges is created is born and that
somehow people can measure or not
observe because a lot of this stuff is
uh microscopic so they cannot observe it
like see with their eyes they can
measure something there and they call
this Behavior a particle
that's what's going to happen here okay
so it says arising when a
microscopically complicated system such
as a solid behaves as if right behaves
as it it contains different weekly
interacting particles in vacuum the
aggregate motion of electrons for
example okay uh Collective excitations
include the phonon and quasi-particle
derived from vibrations of atoms in a
solid and the plasmons a particle
particle derived from plasma
oscillations so they call it a particle
but we're not talking about a particle
we're talking about a bunch of moving
things collectively called a particle
okay it's like you're saying what is the
table well tables all these atoms and
the electrons are moving within atoms so
a table is a bunch of moving electrons
no no that's not what a table is table
is what I point to that's called a table
but see these people are turning
Concepts Dynamic Concepts into a
physical object they're saying uh that
this movie is a photograph
called a quasi particle and at the
bottom another source says equation
particle refers to a physics concept
okay concept a concept is a particle
in which highly stimulated states of
matter are viewed as Elementary Quantum
particles in their own right again
they're turning a concept they're
telling you right in your face that you
know they're turning this concept into
an object into a thing into a particle
and you would think a particle you know
because when people think of particles
they think of a you know a tiny little
ball something like this you know they
say that's a particle maybe a little
smaller than this one right uh we're
talking about a speck of dust grain of
sand maybe a seed Tiny Seed that's a
particle that's what people imagine for
a particle and so they use the word
particle but particle is very very
misleading because it has nothing to do
with particle with the notion that
everybody has in their minds of what a
particle is
okay so here we have
um
uh what a particle is we talked about
this the other day particle is
essentially a field okay so you have
this field whatever a field is it just
covers the entire universe
some kind of field maybe gravitational
field the electric field uh magnetic
field you have all these fields out
there and they're all somehow different
electric Universe says it's all the same
okay great but we have these fields we
don't know what this field is okay and
somehow it's vibrating locally okay and
so here it is an illustration of the
field vibrating locally and it's going
to be known as a particle here it is
okay so that's a particle particle is
some kind of vibration of this uh web
that extends all the way to the edge of
space time if space time has an edge
okay and it's vibrating and it's known
as a particle okay so now we know what a
field is I mean what a particle is it's
a vibration a local vibration of a field
okay so what is a quasi well the Quasi
if you take many of these now we're
going to take many of these and we're
going to build a quasi with it because
it's a collective
um or a collection of particles that are
moving essentially here it is okay so
that's a quasi the whole thing okay not
one of those but all of them that's
known as a quasi so we have the the
single one and you have the many okay so
we get you get the idea hopefully that
we have a local vibration of a field
that's going to be a particle we have
many of these particles and that's going
to be the Quasi okay
and uh so but what is a field you know I
mean you saw those little lines what are
they what are we talking about
what do we I mean if you see a
hummingbird vibrating you say okay
that's a hummingbird but I can take a
snapshot of that and say okay where do I
get it when I take a snapshot well I get
a hummingbird I get some kind of bird
some object in front of me that has
shame right uh but when you do that with
the field uh you don't get uh these
little lines what you get is a bunch of
numbers because the field is defined
as a bunch of numbers that are vibrating
so here it is this is a field it says a
field a physical quantity that has a
value for each point in space and time
and so what is a physical quantity well
it's a physical property of a material
or system that can be Quantified by
measurement and they talk about you know
the given example of 32.3 kilograms
being a physical quantity of mass okay
great and so what is a physical property
it says any property that is measurable
whose value describes etc etc etc in
other words it's a property and it
describes it's measurable and that has
very little to do with physics it's got
to do a lot to do with mathematics
mathematics because we don't measure in
in physics and we do not describe what
we do in physics is explained we need to
explain how the universe works anybody
can describe a chair and say how that
it's brown that it's got four legs got a
back rest you know you can describe a
chair does that make you a scientist
because you can describe it both
qualitatively and quantitatively
and what is the property well property
is a characteristic of an object a red
object is said to have the property of
redness okay so the uh just some feature
that an object has okay so if that's
what uh a field eventually is then we're
not saying much about you know we're not
saying that it's an object it's a
property of an object and there you have
a measurement what is it the
quantification of attributes of an
object or event okay so we have a bunch
of Concepts that's all we have we have
no physical objects so far we don't know
what a field is because it's just a
bunch of numbers a physical quantity
that is valued at each point in space
and time and there you have it uh
there's there's your field on the right
okay and if it vibrates well you have a
particle
and if a lot of them vibrate uh well
then you have what is known as a quasi
particle okay quasi-particle or whatever
and so here's a a summary of that uh the
conclusions okay
uh you have the field what is it excited
values
uh what is a particle it's an excited
field okay it was a quasi particle it's
so many excited particles
so now you know what all these things
are you know what a quasi is yeah a
crazy quasis
okay so that's it the one of the problem
we have here is that um you don't find
uh any of these in the standard model I
mean if these are particles you would
think that you know you could fill the
standard model within here's the
standard model okay and you don't see
any quasis in there and you say well why
not
well maybe because they're not
fundamental you know and um
you know they've taken a lot of the
fundamental ones out of there do we know
whether the electron is fundamental do
we know whether the muon is fundamental
I mean maybe they're made out of more
sub parts
are they going to remove the muon and
the electron once we find you know what
to put in there
you know so so this is this is the issue
the issue is uh are they ever going to
reach a fundamental particle
are they interested in reaching a
fundamental particle uh how do they plan
to get there I mean uh smash
uh particles forever with uh ever bigger
colliders to see what if if you can
smash that particle what you get out of
it and then you uh you take the electron
you break it into pieces you call that
the A and the b or the c or whatever
yeah is that what the
what these scientists do you know they
just smash particles and give them names
without understanding anything you know
okay so
um if they're not in a standard model
where do you find the quasies the
quasides well here you have there's a
list of them in the uh Wikipedia and you
can find all of them there are all the
ones that I guess they found to date or
that they invented today and what are we
staring at we're staring at a list of
so-called particles quasi particles and
what are they they are just Collective
behaviors
so they have a collective behavior of
many atoms and they call these motions
as these interrelated emergent
properties of this collection of atoms
or particles or whatever
assuming they're particles right and uh
and whatever Behavior they have they
call that a particle they call it a
quasiak particle
so it's the craziest thing on Earth you
know I mean it makes no sense whatsoever
uh certainly the word particle in there
is very misleading because people say oh
a quasi-particle some kind of exotic
particle no it's not a particle at all
it's a behavior of many particles that's
what it is emergent properties that come
out from
single particles which they don't
understand to begin with but then they
have the collection of them they have
some emergent behavior and they call
that whole thing now a particle and
they're referring not to the
to the individual to a thing they're
referring to the behavior of all these
particles so if you have the uh you know
the wind blowing all the trees in a
forest you have a quasi
a quasiang forest uh whatever you know
you have the motion of all the trees
that's more that's what it's all about
and uh here you have uh one uh
group of so-called physicists and they
have created a new magnetic
quasi-particle City of College City
College of New York Center for Discovery
and innovation of the physics department
have announced the creation of a new
type of what magnetic quasi-particle
generated by coupling light to a stack
of ultra thin two-dimensional magnets
okay and so what is all this about what
do you mean they've discovered a
particle says this breakthrough lays the
foundation for an emerging strategy to
artificially design materials by
ensuring their strong interaction with
light
well it sounds like they're talking
about technology and not about science
okay
uh says implementing our approach one of
the uh fellows who worked on the project
implementing our approach with Magnetic
materials is a promising path towards a
fishing Magneto Optical effects
achieving this goal can enable their use
for applications in everyday devices
like lasers or for digital data storage
these people these arrogant uh so-called
physicists they're not physicists at all
these people are into technology they're
into doing measurements giving names to
things and they don't understand any not
a bit of what they're doing they don't
understand what's going on all they know
they measure they they whatever they
effect they are able to measure and they
say oh we can use this for this
technology
but that's what's that got to do with
understanding what a quasi particle is
you know I mean uh you're taking this
collection Collective behavior and
you're saying we can use it
you still don't understand what it is
like taking a magnet and saying oh look
a magnet picks up iron filings
I can use this for something
yeah but you cannot explain how
the magnet attracted the iron foundings
that's what we want that's what a
physicist wants to understand but to say
that it does
and we've proven it we've measured it we
know how fast it does and all this uh
all these descriptions and saying I can
use it for technology
that doesn't make you a scientist it
doesn't make you a physicist because you
still don't understand squat that's the
issue okay and so one fella asked the
question he said
um uh I I in really in in relation to
what I had said I said a physicist is an
individual who can explain the physical
mechanism that underlies phenomena such
as gravity magnetism electricity or the
workings of the animal
okay so that's what a physicist is
physicist is someone who can explain a
mechanism you have to explain how the
universe works how Mother Nature does
things how Mother Nature does gravity
how does magnetism electricity and so on
that's what you have to explain as a
physicist but to say that you know the
magnet picks up iron filings and the
spoon always falls to the floor and
enduring gravity and so you haven't
explained anything all you did was
Observe measure and say
um I was able to measure how fast or how
much it weighed or whatever how much
time it took that doesn't make you a
scientist you're not using your brain
when you do that all you're doing is
measuring and making a little equation
that represents your measurement
that's not a scientist so Phil says I
don't get it no physics can explain all
this either
yeah but a physicist can but you're
you're confusing these people for
physicists they're mathematicians okay
so we have to explain what a
mathematical physicist is is okay and
people these people call themselves
physicists when they're not physicists
they're mathematical physicists with
quotations they're mathematicians that's
all they are and all they can do is
describe measure give you an equation
they cannot explain how this universe
works which they dismissed as philosophy
physical interpretations they say that's
not part of science so when people go to
places like war and they say look I want
to know how how this works how that
works how do you do gravity how do you
do electricity these people begin with
equations says oh we understand we
understand the equations when you say
well how does it work oh that part we
don't understand because that's not part
of our job description
so yeah they dismiss explanations as
philosophy and that's where the problem
is we have to determine what science is
what physics is and for the last 400
years since the so-called scientific
revolution in the 17th century the
mathematicians took over
and they started doing measurements and
experiments and equations
and here we are 400 years later not one
of them can tell you
you know how this what causes this spoon
to fall to the floor to fall downwards
what is pulling on
or pushing if you want to do it they
cannot come up with a mechanism
especially with a push mechanism there's
no mechanism you can do uh represent
gravity with push push gravity
anyways that's the issue the issue is
that we have this quasi Quasar particle
and it's just a behavior that they
observe meaning that they measure the
effect they call that an observation and
they can use it for some technology to
develop or in some way they have no idea
what's happening in that tiny world
called a quasi-particle which is a
movement of a bunch of particles each
one is a vibrating field and no one
knows what a field is other than you
know a bunch of numbers in other what is
it just measurements taken of the
strength of maybe a gravitational field
or an electric field or a magnetic field
so they measure the strength and it dies
off
the farther away you get from Ground
Zero and then they have those values and
they say well it's a vibrating field so
what are they vibrate the numbers
because they still don't know what a
field is
and that's where it all ends up
that's it for that for the Quasi
anyways we had uh our uh science uh
critic and he had something to say
especially about the word object and so
let's see uh what he had to say and how
we address it let me put him on for you
to hear here goes
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include
our definitions ground in stone
and kind of common definitions we find
in dictionaries and encyclopedias be
used in science
is the definition of object we find in
the Wikipedia scientific
can it be used in physics
so here is the thing
the definition of objects that
dictionaries list is the most commonly
used definition and that is because most
people want to know how a word is
commonly used it may not necessarily be
the scientific definition
so why didn't he use a scientific
definition however physics has a
different definition of an object and
that definition is a collection of
matter within a defined contiguous
boundary in three-dimensional space that
is a pretty good definition of an object
I must say one that even Bill might
agree with
is he kidding me
no not even by a long shot anyways uh
these are my answers to
the issues he raised okay first one is
he says why didn't Bill use the
scientific definition
well the reason I didn't use it there
ain't one there is no scientific
definition of the word object and that's
the problem out there okay in
mathematical physics there isn't one
because the mathematicians have no
interest in objects they do not do
physics with objects they do physics
with numbers and they call it physics
like I just explained a little while ago
they have never realized that in order
to provide a physical interpretation to
a physical phenomenon especially when a
mediated by invisible intangible
entities right you absolutely need
objects and you can't do without them
mathematician mathematician right give
live service to the collection of matter
definition anyways okay they use the C
touch anyways okay so they don't use
this collection of matter but even if
they did it would not be a scientific
definition because matter is the word
that we're trying to Define here okay
the scientific exclamation uses the
irrational seat touch criteria
nevertheless the collection of matter is
an irrational definition of object
because matter is what we're trying to
figure out what it is
so the definition of object is that
which has shape which is a universal
property that all objects have so no
under no circumstances do I
agree with the collection of matter
because all they're saying is a table is
a collection of atoms that's called
muriology okay no so is an elephant so
it is a tree everything is a collection
of matter a collection of atoms that
does not make an object
an object is not a collection it is a
forest an object because it's a
collection of trees
okay so this is the problem you cannot
have collections of anything uh to to
define the word object shape is the only
um property that all objects have it's a
universal property of objects so it
should be defined on the basis of shape
and not on the basis of what objects do
such as see and touch or collect
together you know gather together
so yeah no this file has no clue
whatsoever what a definition is and he
says oh to me it's a good definition uh
well that's because he he doesn't have
much of a brain to analyze these things
in any detail that's where the problem
is
okay folks so let's get down to some of
the questions and comments that people
have since last time here's one fellow
says sometimes math gives you
inadmissible results now if you take an
inadmissible result as an admissible one
then you go on a wild Chase okay Fields
explain how an object there will behave
as if affected by a force yeah and
Fields don't explain anything because
fields are Concepts if you want an
explanation you need objects you need to
identify what physical object is going
to be doing the acting the behavior okay
and field is not an object we just
discussed it's just a bunch of numbers
and you can't say that uh the bunch of
numbers explains right uh how something
can behave now a bunch of numbers cannot
explain they can describe but not
explain okay mathematically a field is
force vectors in 3D space a the
mechanism of that Force has yet to be
discovered well no it has been
discovered it's been discovered here uh
it just hasn't reached the public yet
okay but it has been discovered okay all
we have to do is now spread it out okay
specifically the force of gravity
magnetic force and electric static Force
yeah we we discovered uh because what
you have to discovered what you have to
discover is the invisible intangible
mediators
that are performing uh gravity magnet uh
electricity all all these uh phenomena
you have to discover the invisible
intangible objects once you discover
those it's easy because now you can
visualize what's happening in that
invisible world can anyone prove If
gravity is a pushing or pulling force uh
we don't prove in science okay but we
have uh proposed that gravity is a
pulling Force because a pulling
mechanism not force but it's a pulling
mechanism
um
so we do have an explanation a mechanism
to propose whether people believe it or
not that's their personal business
are we pulled down to earth or pushed
down to earth well let's see if uh
someone can answer that here we have uh
one fellow his name is uh Richard
Mueller I'm pulling put him on here
before let me put him against if you
listen carefully to him he'll show you
that remedy is a pull Force okay here it
goes here here carefully
what's the force of grounded on me
um
it's the pull of the Earth on my body
so for example if you have the Earth
when it's a big Messier and you have you
with your little Mass here
at every atom on the Earth
is pulling on every atom of you
you're also pulling on it
they've had a lot of atoms here you're
pulling on you're pulling on all of them
amazing thing about gravity is it goes
right through things
okay so um I guess they've determined as
a pull force of some kind the Earth is
pulling on you nothing is pushing on you
okay in fact when you lift your arms up
you feel that something's pulling From
Below not something pushing you from
above and I was there with with this as
well with my little magnets okay
uh nothing is pushing from the outside
you can feel the tug already from the
inside in fact
you can see how how it's talking from
the inside it's obviously it's something
in between and not outside of the
magnets but uh people are still trying
to figure that out when it's already
been decided
gravity and uh magnetism at least right
uh attraction right are pulling forces
so you have to figure out what's between
two magnets and what's between you and
the Earth that's what you got to figure
out anyone trying to do push
gravity you know uh like some people
proposed uh well he's he's gonna have a
hard time uh explain the mechanism
illustrating the mechanism what's he
going to illustrate a bunch of particles
pushing you from above you know what's
pushing you
so yeah we've already figured out what
um that uh gravity is a pull Force okay
now uh here we have uh two examples okay
uh one is uh particles pushing on an
astronaut towards Earth this is what it
would look like and particles should be
coming from everywhere on uh in the
universe why would they come from One
Direction only pushing the astronaut in
a given Direction you know there's got
to be particles also pushing from the
other side of of the earth okay and why
are those particles going in a given
Direction and not in another Direction
okay so I'm not sure how you can explain
but I welcome anyone who can explain
right
um you know uh push gravity I I want an
illustration I don't want any equations
anything like that I want a mechanism
show me the mechanism uh with uh ropes
no problem here it is
you can see why the astronauts be
falling to Earth he's not really being
pulled by The Rose what happens as you
get closer to the Earth the rose fan out
and so he travels faster and faster and
faster because more what I call
effective ropes intervene in this
process
there it is so if you compare these two
you can see there
the astronaut uh
being pushed by particles you know how
do you explain that especially if a
particles going every direction
okay so yeah we do have an explanation
for gravity and it's a pull Force like
uh uh Richard Mueller explained okay
they figured out that it's a full force
but they can't figure out what it is
that is pulling that's the whole problem
and for that you have to make the
invisible objects visible so that people
understand the theory you can visualize
what's happening and then you're done
now you understand the theory whether
you believe it or not your problem
doesn't concern science at all science
only concerns mechanisms okay and here
we have another phone says why do you
think the speed of light is constant is
it based solely on the Michaelson and
Marty experiment
I don't think that a sand clock going
slower or faster Alters the rate of time
uh yeah okay the constant speed of light
would alter the speed of time however
because of Pythagoras uh theorem which
really all which really all that Sr is
based on
now the the reason uh not that we
believe we don't use the word believe or
no in science uh we propose we make an
assumption okay we theorize and the
proposal is that you have a rope okay
that binds any two atoms and for a given
length of rope okay you can have many
links or fewer links if you have many
links the links should be shorter and if
you have fewer links the link should be
low uh longer and that's what the
constant uh little C indicates uh little
C uh is equals to frequency times
wavelength is really little C equals to
more Links of a rope and each link is
longer or vice versa you have fewer
Links of the Rope okay and each link is
longer and that is the equation of a
rope that's why it's a constant
nothing to do with Michaelson more the
experiment okay
okay another fellow says
when mankind encountered entanglement it
was understood by mathematicians okay
that physical connections atoms to all
other atoms is physically impossible
Einstein called it spooky action at a
distance well why why is it physically
impossible okay you gotta explain that's
just a statement that's just a belief
that's just the you know
defending a religion you know say it's
physically impossible what do you mean
explain why is it okay Suppose there are
only 10 atoms in the universe physically
connecting Adam to all others would be
90 connections okay double the amount of
atoms from 10 to 20 increase the number
of physical connections required from 90
to 380 that's mathematical exponential
growth well okay so you know a little
bit of arithmetic great what we have
observed of the universe so far amounts
to an accurate estimate I like that he's
got an accurate estimate okay of 10 to
the 82nd power of atoms okay that's what
you observed the universe is a little
bigger than the observed and we don't
care about observations because you know
we don't know what you observed and we
don't care about testimonies in science
if the universe is infinite it would it
can't be infinite because universe is
not a physical object therefore it can't
be uh infinite even if it were a
physical object there is no object that
is infinite all objects are finite and
the universe is not an object the
universe is an abstract concept meaning
objects and space okay but says is
infinite it would just completely
saturate out with physical connection no
if it's infinite you would think you
know I mean if they extended forever
then you can put as many as you want in
there so it would never saturate uh so a
guy contradicts himself at every step he
says at the size of the known observed
Universe okay he's talking about the
known Do You observe what he can see
through a telescope right 10 to the 67
000 Etc power physical connections would
be required that would be analogous to
tie trying to put a billion fish in a
tank with capacity for five fish
not enough space impossible for physical
connections Adam to all other atoms well
yeah I mean uh poor fellow he he thinks
that um
uh this is an issue of quantity oh he
says there's a lot of atoms in the
universe yeah no kid I mean uh you can
put any number you want to that because
we we have no idea how big or how much
matter there is in the universe and
hopefully all matter is made out of
atoms so there's got to be atoms on the
other side of the universe that we have
encountered because we have no idea how
big you know all this matter this chunk
of matter is in the universe the
thread and a single thread that makes up
all matter we don't know how big it is
how how and it doesn't matter it's it's
irrelevant the question is you know uh
he says that if you have many atoms you
have many connections and many
connections would not fit within space
because space is infinite
well if J is infinite you can fit as
much as you want and if it's finite uh
then you have to tell us what's outside
of space giving shape to space
okay so that's how it is now you can put
as many connections as you want because
seed touch is not the criteria that we
use to define the word object and that's
the bottom line that's the big problem
that this fellow has in reasoning once
you once you um Define objects and that
has that which you can see and touch but
that which has shape then see and touch
are irrelevant and this fellow is
essentially focusing on C and touch he
says oh it would be touching each other
bouncing it would be Tangled and you
couldn't fit them all in there
you know
he said nothing he just said that
there's a lot of atoms in the universe
that's all he said okay Paul says in
physics an object is an identifiable
collection of matter which we just
covered okay which may be constrained by
an identifiable boundary all these
people just copy paste and they say this
is what I found in the not even
addiction it's in the uh encyclopedia
the Wikipedia okay okay but even if it's
uh in the Wikipedia or in a dictionary
so what identify a collection of matter
nothing is an an elephant is also an a
uh collection of matter is that what he
is is that how we're going to Define
elephant and tree and table and rock
they're just collections of matter
whatever that means what do you mean by
matter well that's a bunch of atoms and
what's an atom well that's a object the
word we're trying to Define
so we're back to they're going around in
circles yeah no it's not identifiable or
unidentifiable collection of matter
matter is the word we're trying to
Define okay and before you can Define
matter you have to define the word
object so you cannot Define the word
matter before you define the word object
or or use the word matter to define the
word object which may be constrained Etc
okay by a boundary and he gives little
importance to that right and may move
may move well if it moves or not we we
don't care uh motion comes afterwards we
don't need the word move to define the
word object okay as a unit or by
translation or rotation Etc okay the
dumbest pseudoscience sentence ever
spoken is object is that which has shape
okay yeah because it destroys the
religion right when shape isn't even a
variable in defining objects not even a
variable not even a property
I don't know about variable I don't know
what he means by a variable we're not
talking about variables we're talking
numbers you know we're talking about uh
qualitative stuff here we're saying what
is the only property all objects have in
the universe and that is uh shape okay
um objects require a three-dimensional
collection of atoms
well again Adam uh if if that's what an
object requires you have to Define what
an atom is and you got to tell me if an
atom is an object that we're back to
square one we're we're going around in
circles anyways matters uh objects move
is a verb it means that you need to have
an object to have motion because motion
is two or more locations of an object
and atoms are objects so he did was
Chase his tail around with his uh
definition which is which ain't his he
just copied it pasted and says oh
there's there you have a definition yeah
it's when people don't analyze the
definitions that they find and they just
use them as they find they get copy
paste said well that's good enough for
me and and they run with that
yeah another fellow says says the
universe does not have shape or location
in relation to anything else
no no the universe does not have shape
period
okay universe is a concept there is no
physical object called Universe Universe
matter and space
okay two things do not when an object
make an object is Standalone does not
require something else okay so uh
universe is not an object universe is a
concept Universe means matter and space
okay uh matter being all the objects
uh that float with respect to each other
okay out there in nothingness because
there is nothing else okay well we don't
know
uh whether there is something else in
other words we have not observed we have
not measured right we cannot verify so
we don't care about that so what we say
is we postulate we make an assumption
that there is something else how's that
okay that there is a parallel universe
what do we mean by that well we mean by
that that well he says continue says
therefore the universe God does not
exist using Bill's definition of
existence not only definition of
existence but Universe already fails the
definition of object and only objects
may be said to exist okay but anyways we
imagine there's two threads there you
have two threads two Universal threats
one is our universe one thread makes up
all the matter in our universe not a
single one of those atoms
is physically connected to the thread
that makes up another chunk of matter
out there floating parallel to our
universe right
uh so we have these two chunks of matter
uh one described by one thread the other
one described by another thread and so
they're not connected we can't see or
touch
their Universe any atom there because
we're not connected to it we especially
we cannot see it and so assuming there
is another thread out there or maybe
several maybe gazillions of threads for
all we know chunks of matter that are
not connected to our universe well then
um then you would have the word exist in
that context because now one Universe
exists with respect to another universe
okay and so we have to do is postulate
make an assumption that there is a
parallel universe two threads okay one
thread makes the matter in r uh Universe
we could call it you know Universe one
okay our Island and the other one makes
up that one over there
the funny thing about that is they
happen to crisscross you know these two
Universe some matter
um we would not see them but we would
probably be hit by something
talking about ghosts and you know and
Goblin days like today
Halloween
uh yeah you could have that situation of
course I can't imagine that something
like that would ever happen because for
two universes to crisscross we can't
even have galaxies crisscrossing barely
you know after billions of years uh I
can't imagine two universes Crossing
could happen maybe somewhere
okay another fellow says even the atoms
in a photograph are in a constant state
of motion just like the atoms on a
screen so so again all these people they
get lost they get lost they don't know
what a single frame of a film means uh
when you look at a single frame of the
film you're talking about a
cross-section of the universal movie
nothing is moving not even an electron
in that frame because we're
conceptualizing a single frame and he
doesn't understand that he says oh even
within a friend there's electrons moving
so so portfolio doesn't have a mental
capacity to understand this anything
that is perfectly still is undetectable
to us well for first of all there
nothing no one's talking about
detectable to begin with second nothing
can be perfectly uh still in the
universe no object can be perfectly
still because as soon as you move you
move with respect to that object okay
because uh if I want to move God all I
have to do is move my pinky and I'll
move God whether he likes it or not okay
he may want to stand still and say oh
you can't move me and I'll move him
anyways all you got to do is move my
pinky
uh so the so he's talking about nonsense
there okay first about detectability and
second about uh something being
perfectly still you can't have one thing
perfectly still if you're going to talk
about Stillness in the universe you have
to postulate that a single frame in the
Universal movie is a cross-section of
time there is no motion whatsoever in
that frame not even an electron moves in
that brain you made it you conceptualize
it as being static
and I don't know if that sunk into his
little brain matter is merely simulated
by motion of the phenomenal medium he
says matter is ether in motion well yeah
all these people talk about these ether
there but they never tell you what ether
is they never will tell you what ether
is because they cannot tell you that and
so we Define either the way it's always
been defined bunch of particles that's
what ether means that's what ether is
and then he says space or energy is
ether at rest but just any nonsense that
comes out of his little mind I mean this
poor fellow
uh space and energy
is either standing still
but if I move I move my hand isn't The
Ether standing still whatever ether is
isn't it moving with respect to my hand
isn't its location changing is it the
distance between my hand and this ether
changing
he doesn't have the mental capacity for
such simple things
they don't have the mental capacity
that's that's the issue and so you're
talking to a wall
okay and uh here you have another phone
he says what is E equals m c squared
okay according to Einstein it is mass
multiplied by speed of light squared
okay can Mass be multiplied by the
square of light speed can light speed or
velocity be square
the issue the issue here is that you
know you're not talking to physicists
when you talk about this stuff you're
talking to mathematicians okay and so
they you know you can't say uh can I can
I Square the elephant
can I Square the tree can I Square The
Rock can I have Rock times Rock
and of course they can't do that
so they never deal with objects because
they can't put an object in any equation
and say okay rock time's wrong so what
they say is mass times mass they look at
the mass of they measure how much the
mass the The Rock weighs and they say
that it's got so much mass this one has
so much mass and I'm going to multiply
the masses
they don't know why they have to
multiply it just works but they don't
know why they have to multiply them and
likewise when they take the speed of
light you know you don't say lifetimes
light assuming as they always assume
right that light is two little particles
let me get rid of this
you know if you uh
if you have two little particles right
you have photons times photon
or what sense does that make what do you
mean Photon times photon
so what they do is they said okay forget
about the photon we're going to look at
what is the speed of the photon they're
going to take that 300 000 kilometers
per second they're going to multiply
times another 300 000 kilometers per
second in other words 300 000 kilometers
per second squared right they're going
to multiply it and they're going to do
some calculation with mass and energy
they have never explained they cannot
explain why uh they're multiplying these
two quantities
what what it means in physical terms
okay and I explained it the other day uh
last uh lecture uh it essentially means
that the meaning of light squared means
that
an atom any atom in the universe just
one atom sends light to all other atoms
in the universe and they send light back
why because every atom in the universe
is physically connected to all others
light travels through or torques really
the Rope torques between any two apps
that's the meaning of light squared in
math you will never find an answer
with that I'll see you next week
possibly on next Tuesday okay because
I'm I'm floating around running around
traveling and so I'll probably see you
next Tuesday we'll see you then bye